[Music]
joining me today is a guy who's seen an
awful lot of people get hit in the nuts
a man who's lived in a house that
constantly seems to be getting fuller
and a stand-up comic whose new special
zero-to-sixty is now streaming on Amazon
Bob Saget welcome to the Reuben report
thank you I'm excited to be here you're
a very smart man I cannot keep up with
you mentally but we did have dinner and
I seem to keep up with the entrees is
that why you were applying me with so
much alcohol during dinner too kind of
dumb me down no I just said that we
could get on the level I wanted to see
what you were like unconscious yeah we
did good because rats the world Britain
right now that's an opposite day kind of
statement in other words years ago when
you would say I want to see what you're
like unconscious that would be a joke
but unfortunately we are in a world
right now where that's actually happened
so a lot of things that are irreverent
and could be considered funny or not
yeah and so there's this buffering that
goes on before but either way you did
not get overly inebriated and you were
more than pleasant and we had a lovely
night with both of our significant
others who we both adore and we laughed
and and we had good food yeah and we
will do it again we will do it again and
that's all I want to talk about but I
don't talk about my career what do we
have as entree well I believe I had the
fish you did I think you had something
not as healthy date I think it was maybe
no I didn't know you didn't say you had
some kind of chicken something maybe all
right let's focus here Saget come here
that's a good place to start what you
just did there just the state of
political correctness let's just do a
little bit on Madeleine I want to do
Saget 101 all right for this next hour
I'm teaching that course at a community
college yeah yeah how many kids are
taking it it doesn't matter whoever
replies that doesn't turn me in you let
him wallet everybody comes in yeah send
a trailer what do you think of that
you're doing this we're live to tape so
right we don't edit and this did not
exist four years ago this existed but it
didn't exist like this I mean you got
millions of people that watch this yeah
this is crazy
what do you think about that like you're
used to doing I mean obviously I want to
talk stand up and everything else but
you do scripted series
yes you do movies things like that but
you also do you do panel on talk shows
things that are sort of they're kind of
old school now like that's very
different than coming in here and right
before we started I said to you we're
just gonna go for it you were like
whatever you want I mean I don't have to
look I can just do that yeah you can
yeah what you get a little bit back
again and those are the smallest cards
I've ever seen your interviews of
microfiche it's just I just write little
silly things no that looks all smart I
love the fact that this exists because
years ago if you wanted to go on a show
and have a one-on-one with someone it
was you or a baby but it was Tom
Schneider maybe all of you do oh yeah
getting that that you might be tiny bit
older than a baby yeah the camera was
always very close to his incredibly
close at Dan Aykroyd on Sarah Night Live
and the very beginning we know an
impression of it yeah and was this tight
and he would be smoking and tom was just
talking to camera yeah do his discourse
which is very much like a podcast is
today like Bill burr friend of mine gets
up in the morning talks for an hour once
a week it's unbelievable to listen to a
lot of our great podcasters that's the
everything has changed and in that
regard this has changed for the better
because you get to have an articulate
conversation that you can't normally
have in commercial television because
commercial televisions meant to be
entertaining yeah only I don't know what
we're meant to be over here well
interesting interesting I guess yeah and
my fiancee Kelly turned me on to your
show and I said I really like him and I
like what he's talking about and you had
guests on and you were ever you're able
to be a diplomat which is very difficult
to do when you have people with
different points of view a conservative
and and a liberal which I don't
understand I don't understand any of it
yeah I just what we're gonna get I
understand it but I mean we were mammals
yeah we're supposed to live yeah we're
supposed to be nice to another mammal
and I'm supposed to hunt it and kill it
depends which kind of mammal you are at
if it's delicious
yeah then you have to go for it right
yeah it's just food well we're gonna
we're gonna dive into all that because I
didn't
is that for you it's interesting I think
because your stand-up is so different
than your your television persona
between America's Funniest Home Video is
in Flast well they're the old ones so
but yeah an entourage that'd be kinda
like a thing but then but then I did a
bunch of acting stuff too and I've done
Broadway work which was some of it was
similar to my stand-up but I've always
done something that's every 7 years
there's some new incarnation that people
go who the hell is he yeah well that's
why I think it's interesting because
especially with celebrities people like
to just get in or anyone that's public
that they like to just get a kind of
image of you and then just run with that
forever and you're instantly challenging
I infused to be pigeonholed because it
sounds like something you should not do
to a pigeon now see that's the kind of
joke you guys still do you can still do
that because it's not a human being yeah
it's a pigeon
yeah but only if you know they're gonna
be really upset about that would be the
Humane Society yeah and they are right
the ASPCA is all over the show there
haven't I don't see their name anywhere
anymore
I think they're out you think they're
done I don't know I think it's the ASPCA
NRA
I think it's they've combined so that
you take care of the bird and then you
fire at it it's that gonna fly well on
this show I think it well you know we've
got those chickens out there and one day
people always happened what are you
gonna do when they stop laying eggs are
you just in women's but they're so
beautiful I thought they were males cuz
they had the red millet malay malay was
too calm and we were very excited to say
cockle I said you have three beautiful
[ __ ] well no those are actually those
are female hens that lay eggs and what
are you doing this for the eggs not just
to us Woody Allen yeah which was Groucho
Marx I need the eggs I need the eggs but
that's yeah Annie Hall that's the truth
all right go ahead hi this is a problem
with me as a talk show guest as a
comedian yeah
and as someone without a script I free
associate and I sometimes do not stay on
track but you are so smart and linear
you were going to keep me on track and I
will do my very best to accommodate you
will do my best to accommodate you okay
this is fair let's start at the
beginning you are born in
adelphia I was yeah and Einstein
Hospital
Einstein Hospital yes and then it is
still there is that in honor of Albert
Einstein it is huh it is and it's on
Broad Street
and and I was born there and my dad
worked for a supermarket company called
Food Fair pantry pride supermarkets and
he was a meat executive that all sounds
legit what about your family what what
background what business were they in I
was born in Brooklyn grew up in Long
Island lived in Manhattan my whole life
went to college upstate New York so I'm
a true New Yorker so we're both you had
life I wish I had yeah I was in Philly I
lived at home during college you had it
you had that's why you're smart and I go
out and tell a bunch of wiener jokes I
know but I'm going back into that now as
you know you are you're gonna stand up I
told you I'm going back in this and you
were very excited I'm excited you also
told me you're playing the Irvine improv
yeah and when is that oh that wasn't
even public till just now that's great I
don't hey to say back to April 8th April
it's my first headlining gig in ten
years and this is one of the nicest
clubs in Los Angeles and in anywhere
really I mean it's it's like six hundred
people seven hundred people it looks
like a spaceship it looks like a Disney
exhibit and it's it's an Irvine which is
why they call it the arm Bryan improv
and I couldn't put that together why do
they call the Irvine improv and there's
but I don't know but they're smart
people and and nice people they're you
will bring smart people because you you
have so many people that you will bring
your audience which is that's the
advantage of what we do yeah whatever we
do whatever media we're on that's who
comes to see us that's got to be the
most beautiful shift in comedy right do
you remember that moment when you went
from like being a guy that was just you
know trying to get on 8th out of ten
comics at the end of the night and
nobody knows you are do you remember the
beginning of when people were going I'm
going to see Bob Saget something weird
happened with me which was I started
doing stand-up when I was 17 and I want
to were that that was a seven 73 Wow so
his I'm 104 on the freeway look at that
head of hair though for 100 no very
umbra but I had to do the drops I take
the thing
propecia that's post on the propecia he
seems fine oh please don't compare me to
that that's the hair we'll get there
we'll get my sonic comb over yeah I know
what's gonna happen if we get right on
Trump I actually I I believe but I don't
wanna I'm not doing I'm not doing
anything
to bash anyone I will not do it even
though it's possible that his comb-over
is from an onion in the kitchen that
just snaggletooth along the ground and
then crawls up his back yeah did you see
that moment I saw that video on the
airplane yes that done CGI was that done
with effects because that didn't look
possible it looked pretty it look pretty
fake but let's let's write with Trump
aside I want to talk to them yes because
do you remember that moment when when
things change yeah what happened was I
came out to LA when I had won the
Student Academy Award for a documentary
I made about my nephew who had his face
reconstructed when he was seven and I
won this student Academy Award for
documentary and then I went on at The
Comedy Store the next night and midsi
the owner of the comedy store said you
should work here so I started getting
spots right away Wow and then I started
the fight for that people fight and I
didn't work the door Wow and I was I
guess likeable but strange very strange
jokes like my first joke was I have the
first show I have the brain of a German
Shepherd and the body of a 16 year old
boy and they're both in my car and I
want you to see them now it's just an
odd rambling but it symbolizes I think
it answers the question of how did he
become this because he was that you're
gonna be third person on myself yeah but
and then I started going on a college
tour she put me on a committee Shore for
the comedy stuff with me on a college
tour and I was a guitar act just a
parodies and I would sing while my
guitar gently weeps turn a valve and
water poured out of the guitar and you
could only see it in the first 10 rows
so it doesn't really do work for the big
stage cannot play the Irvine improv of
this bit yeah and then I was headlining
right away so in my early 20s
I'd go out on the road while I was
taking five years of acting classes with
a teacher named Daryl Hickman
in LA while I was doing improv classes
at The Groundlings while I was doing
spots at The Comedy Store I'd go out on
the road and then headline and then make
money but not enough to get a career and
then I was like eight nine years of
hosting the Comedy Store in Westwood and
and that was hard it was but I got to
befriend people that I worshiped which
were Richard Pryor Robin Williams and
David Letterman was one of my first MCS
and and so I was 22 years old and this
the place was it's packed like it was
then kind of now bad sentence but in the
early 80s it was well you could not get
in to any room and every single person
on the lineup was like and I was hosting
a lot of the shows so but then everybody
went off and got TV shows and I was
still at the comedy store hosting and
thinking this is it I'm never gonna make
it and then I got in a Richard Pryor
movie and then I got on a CBS show and a
morning show
could it go condition oh I've seen that
I'm the young dr. Joffe who does all the
jobs that are disgusting that he doesn't
want to do because he's not a real
doctor
sounds like the emcee at a comedy club
exactly the same thing you don't want to
touch people and I remember holding
Garrett Morris from Saturday Night Live
by the testicles and Richard kept
telling me kept telling me to squeeze
harder and that was a reshoot they added
me to that scene I can see that when you
talk about it sort of and I've had this
with a couple other comics that that
were around at that time there's like a
real nostalgia for it do you remember
thinking it was as special what was yeah
but you remember it at the time thinking
like I'm really in a hundred percent
because usually people don't like the
good old days you only remember them
it's cool they were good old days yeah
because you know you're in a place that
is you know in the comedy stars a lot of
history and it's eros is the main room
and there's supposed to be ghosts in
there and Sam Kennison says he saw a
quarter floating in the air of a dead
mobster or something and I believe all
of it I spent a lot of time in there and
it was struggling you know you'd have
people come and see you Rodney
Dangerfield was kind to me
put me on a young comedians special but
it was all you know what I was the
warm-up comic for bosom buddies Tom
Hanks epistolary and it was all
struggling you know but but you need it
but you stand I used to wait in line in
New York at the at The Improv and catch
a rising star for ten hours
uh-huh sign the lineup sheet and wait
for ten twelve hours and I think there's
something if you come out of the the
dugout if you really or the trenches
sorry dugouts fine
yeah means you're gonna you're gonna
you're gonna bat maybe but but if you
come out of the trenches and you you go
through it it's almost oh guy had a
heart attack I've had that happen before
you know you know oh this guy's getting
thrown old disco there's a guy's got a
gun oh yeah yeah that happened to me in
Cleveland I remember that yeah you know
just it gets to the point where you're
almost a pilot on a plane you know it's
like I'm ready for anything
but would you want to do is make people
laugh and that was the hardest
transition for me was to take off the
guitar and to learn to be a comedian
yeah and so was that moment like for you
really hard
I had a guitar on for like four years I
took it off and I bombed for a long time
I would do it I used the club for what
it was supposed to be used for but it
didn't service me it didn't help me get
a sitcom if people saw me they went he's
amicable but he's not funny and I was
trying to do jokes and a lot of them
were there was a talent coordinator for
The Tonight Show I could never get on as
a comic I got on to do panel with Johnny
Carson mm-hmm thanks to Garry Shandling
for putting me on the first time and
then Jay Leno I was on once with him but
then I was done with Carson 13 14 times
and then in and always panel but I never
went on as a comedian because this
talent coordinator who passed on named
Jim McCauley who helped a lot of
people's careers except mine but he did
help me in a way he said you're very
funny but your act is like a stone
skipping on the water it never really
digs in ah thank you wow that's
something to really
take me kung-fu yeah Wow thank you
master take the pebble from my hand yeah
so it hurt me because I couldn't get her
on the damn show but I wasn't
I really wasn't meant to I mean I hate
to say those kind of words you know it's
not meant to be or whatever but it was
hell of a lot better to sit there and
talk a couple segments with Johnny
Carson and him like me and be able to
talk to a guy that you looked up to so
much because he was kind of the master
like that like I'm emanating true
jealousy whenever I hear any of you guys
talk about Carson it's like and and I am
not even making this up because I'm not
delusional he liked me and I still can't
figure that out but I would go I would
say something like and I David Letterman
had a lot of his amazing qualities and
it would respond the same way to this
because one of my patters that I would
say is this is true and Johnny would go
I don't care yeah I don't I don't care
if it's true just tell it David would be
the same thing yeah I would go on
Letterman and I would go this is true
because I don't care if it's true or not
it'd just make it funny just say it I'm
blanking on the title of Bill Maher's
first book the novel that he wrote about
stand-up but the first line in it he
says something about this is true which
is exactly what a comic says when they
were about to tell you something false
correct and that's how that's how the
novel the hell's the name of the book
I'll get it in a second you should know
you I sure this guy I should I know him
I saw a picture
we are donated in reading each other's
books yeah he has a read mine either
true story is the name of the book Oh
true story that's that's that's a branch
ah I also think about this but seriously
folks that is the segue into your next
show yeah our Bob Hope I want to tell
you okay so anyway that's always good
but these are all the tricks so anyway
so I'm in the car well you do learn
tricks yeah you know and if you end it's
always if you can kill them with
kindness or if you can fake sincerity
with their guys during that because
everyone when everyone talks about it's
like you could we could literally spend
the next hour you just naming all stars
right you could just do but we're there
guys
drop I'll just name drop for the next
and it'll be very easy to make a promo
I'll do that professor Irwin Corey see
no one will know that I know but yeah
but but were there guys that you thought
were true heck's transcendent yeah so a
guy like Joe Bill Hicks oh that that's
transcendent yeah that's a guy who
worshipped Sam Kinison it was a friend
of mine I got him is Burt I got Sam his
first spot at The Comedy Store was it in
the documentary no but he was he was an
unusual thing it was an anomaly it was
no one had ever seen that before and
Bill Hicks really thought about why are
we here and had a sweet philosopher in
him it was a gentle George Carlin kind
of thing mm-hmm I mean from know you
know probably saw a gentler version I
did because I I knew him and he was kind
of I knew him when he was really young
yeah I met him he was like 18 or
somethin or 19 and he and he kind of
took to me and and his loss was very sad
it would have loved to have seen what he
would arrived at yeah if he'd been up he
died very young because that that's the
type of comic we need more right
especially now like thoughtful like but
guys that are really saying something
like that yeah I mean you know you
getting back in so maybe I'll find him
on well you can't help but reckon with
Chappelle I mean the man is you know
he's also arguably the the best living
stand-up and reminds you of Richard it
was at that time the best living standup
might be still Lenny Bruce was
decomposed by being arrested not being
allowed to have freedom of speech George
Carlin took it to another level where he
said I'm cutting my hair no more and I'm
going to let myself say the things that
are on my mind it was a lot of anger and
a lot of prophecy and people my mother
didn't like him because he was unkempt
yeah she wanted a kempt person yeah she
would have loved you very much yeah
yeah I don't know recant I'm very Kent
it's a lot of hairspray and she wasn't
she's so smart
and it's handsome all right Saget enough
let's tell you my mother would say but
Carlin having that moment that's like
you putting down the guitar right that's
why I think is I think it's interesting
we can either get good or not it's when
you make that move you like you like
learn something and then you kind of
push start all over again
yeah because you get that you get some
chops you figure out what it's like to
be in front of people and then it's not
an effort it's it's a pleasure
yeah I am you know I'm I'm gonna be 62
in May which is crazy so if you can
delay this that would be great it's not
let it happen yeah yeah but I'm able to
go on stage and I have a gift now having
a special just done that I'm very proud
of this zero to sixty which is from
being zero to being 60 it's brilliant
title Oh daddy's wordy and it's on
Amazon Prime so my joke is there's a
joke with it they with two clicks you
can buy the lotion to watch the special
inferring that that's how aroused you'll
get watching my special yeah you know i
retweeted your special the other day and
then I think you deleted the tweet and I
thought what happened here did you make
mistake in your tweet I did yeah I made
a mistake in my tweet and then I was
like oh oh oh will you do it again let's
see how the rest of this good okay I
know I understand if you don't want to
let's not get ahead I'll show myself out
but but I yeah I had put something wrong
on there because it's it's on many
mediums it's not it's not a Netflix
special but it's on every platform so
it's on I like spectrum DirecTV Google
it so it's never been done like this
till now where they put it on every
on-demand so it's like you can choose
between Wonder Woman or zero to 60 mm
let me think yeah I've much rather much
Bob than Wonder Woman that's pretty cool
though that because right well in the
old days everyone just wanted the HBO
special I mean I remember the day I
started standing up I was like I'm going
to have an HBO I wanted one oh my god
well now you can have all sorts of other
things
many different ways and and Netflix is
kind of the jewel in the crown so is HBO
but they mostly have a few new people
but mostly they're regular team members
but yeah you know bill or George Lopez
of course who is just wonderful I just
like George but this has been a really
cool model on being on Amazon Prime is
actually the world has it you know so
it's it I just wanted it to be seen by
as many people that's all about this
thing and like let's just get it yeah
this this is seen by everybody yeah I
would think right as long as YouTube
lets it get to the feed and YouTube and
now so every person that subscribes you
make money no you do make money if they
roll ads on this we make money but you
may roll ads on this it depends on what
we talk about so you may be deemed too
controversial
- I'm not controversial about fuller
house that's on Netflix is a very
family-oriented show yeah what do you
need to sell what product would help you
make money on this well well you know
whatever they want to lay in before this
I don't care what they put in before
that's the funny thing no one associates
the ad with the content you know so they
just want me not to say anything
offensive so that the advertiser won't
say okay Saget talked about whatever
like a fabric softener chains one of
those sheets that's like a good thing I
would love that fabric I don't know I
like fabrics off it's great stuff we did
and I said to me what a bounce you have
on your jacket yeah that was perfect
perfect picked out outfit and we
complement each other I feel good about
this I am surprised yeah he is I think
we're crushing this house thing hit it
had not heard of it until I did a little
research for this right parently it was
a big succumb oh yes it was it was for
eight years and I didn't know either
yeah I just do I had a place to go to
work and then I would paid for kids
private school yeah so I told you this
when we had dinner a couple weeks ago
but my sister was she's nine years
younger than me she was so and I know
you hear this all the time but she was
so obsessed yeah with that show that we
were never allowed to watch TV at dinner
in my family that was it we we would sit
and and have a good time or a bad time
or argue or laugh or whatever but my
sister at some point took control
the family and suddenly full house was
being watched during dinner write you a
love she loves temos everyone loves
David yeah it's true everyone loves
Namath no do you tell me a little bit
about getting in on that and how that
differed from stand-up and then suddenly
even though you had studied acting and
all that but just like doing something
that was so different completely
different I'd always wanted to be on a
sitcom I'd been around them you know I
did as I said I was a warm-up on Bosom
Buddies I would go visit Robin doing
Mork and Mindy I would sneak into Happy
Days I snuck into the Bob Newhart show I
was underage you had to be 16 or 17 I
snuck into Mary Tyler Moore I would
watch some filming these shows James L
Brooks producing Mary Tyler Moore Show
unbelievable and I saw Bob Newhart last
night had the name drop wants to know
when we can go to dinner didn't mention
you that's Don Rickles that that is a
direct lift of the kind of thing he
would say I mean that's perfection yes
that really is comedy yeah he would say
something like somebody very famous you
know I saw someone last night I saw I
saw Chris Rock last night didn't mention
you you know this just let you know that
Rickles could make it now just because
of the way we are about he was making it
in as an individual as a new young
comedian impossible but there's a new
way to do it which is a way of love and
some people do it and some people make
fun of everyone my friend Jeff Ross is
the roastmaster general you know there
there are ways to bash people but it's
turned mean and what happened is and
this is an understatement
you know the Rose I was roasted on
Comedy Central yeah I had John Stamos
was the roast master I had all my
friends were there I got to pick who was
on it most people don't you know Justin
Bieber roast no one knows him you know
knows the people and people think
roasting people is supposed to be mean
and it's a if it doesn't come out of
kindness and love of the person or just
blind I'm going to attack them but
there's no attachment of anger
this it's just evil it's just wrong and
we are in a society where people will
they'll hit you back on a tweet they'll
watch something you'll see people on the
news you'll listen to political leaders
talk you'll hear people bash each other
back and forth and it comes from Don
Rickles thinking that that's what he did
mm-hmm that's not what the man did the
man would would just you know see a man
and a woman in the audience and say is
this your wife the guy would go yes and
DOM and go oh ho that's just but in his
age had something to do with it but also
his tenacity uh-huh and his and he
started in the lounge at 2:00 in the
morning doing three shows till 5:00 in
the morning yeah and talk about the
trenches and all love so if someone
comes out and makes fun of people and
does it out of love or does it have a
truth that's the safest way we're at
right now that's where the Chappelle
thing comes to that's where you look at
certain people I really enjoy Marc Maron
a lot bill burr I mean there's so many
people that are so good that that some
people don't even know about that
sellout places constantly that are just
like Brian Regan and just he's so he's
brilliant I mean here's three two hours
he's like what and it's clean where you
go see Seinfeld do what he does you go
that's why I'm Jerry side yeah because
it's not just word Smith he's connected
to everything he did it might be word
for word in some ways but another night
but my god it's fun yeah and you know
and then I'll you know I love anybody
who is funny who just is there to
entertain people and it's not only about
them which is hard because we're a very
narcissistic group right I mean comics
are particularly there's a certain breed
of craziness right that comes to comedy
the best line I ever heard about that
was was I've mentioned this a few times
George Carlin on the view once and he's
sitting there with all the women around
him all right talking about you know he
was given
was he was selling or they had just come
out with like this anthology so that's
what he was there for but he said
something about how to be a good comic
you have to have a ton of [ __ ] like you
have to have all this pain and all this
angst and all this stuff but then at
some point you got a conquer it because
otherwise it'll conquer you and that's
why so many comics die of drug overdoses
and all this other stuff and so on so
are dying young in art and yeah but if
you can own it then you could be 62 and
what I'm gonna be doing I don't know if
I make doing stand-up at 90 but I'll be
doing forms of it ya know
you couldn't stop even if you wanted to
right I could not stop working III just
directed this movie Benjamin which I'll
talk about at length in the third hour
of our interview but but I have to leave
after hour - but you're welcome - I'm
gonna stay yeah we're just gonna keep
going just could be me and the camera
but but I I love working without it I
I'm an artist and it sounds so Fruity
Pebbles to say that but I just am and I
always will be and I'll be making
whether it be directing or writing or
performing I love acting there's no
limit as long as you can stand and walk
and Bend and remember things you know
you know yeah not fall into an open
trunk right the memory one goes first
because now there's guys on Broadway
they're using diapir wigs yeah I was
gonna say I be I be what the intercom
type missiles yeah
not those that's it that's it them no no
that has been known and I hopefully will
live long enough that had 92 years old
I'll be on Broadway and I'll have an
earwig in and they'll feed me the lunch
and I don't care if I'm good if it's
done right I saw Peter O'Toole and
Amanda Plummer in my fair lady mm-hmm
the most miscast version of my fair lady
on Broadway and I think he had a thing
in his ear he was no child when he did
it playing that character is very
fascinating because my fair lady which
is a play I don't know if people are
familiar but sometimes the audience
skews a little it's it's a tiny bit
older but it's not a Millennials
favorite but you know she's its
Pygmalion which of course loses more
people Gen X doesn't even follow
Pygmalion right now but it what's
amazing about it is he's 40 years older
than her no matter how you play that
play yeah that is that musical with Rex
Harrison and Audrey Hepburn he's 40
years older than her he is maybe 50 but
he's 60 and she's 20 and that's that and
he's trying to make her a classy woman
in the chauvinistic misogynistic
unacceptable way and it is one of the
best musicals ever written for people
that don't know that was the original
premise of or that was the original
inspiration of pretty woman right way
that is true I'm not making that up no
you're not no you're not he's trying to
make an honest woman yeah out of an
honest hooker yeah all right let's talk
about this full house thing so that
right from honest hooker you did it I
was gonna let you drop one of the girls
names but okay you know so all right so
then you suddenly you're on television
everyone knows who you are
yeah question what a lot of money's is
such a good edit point yeah no we don't
I got offered the job yeah I was fired
from a morning program on CBS which was
against Good Morning America and Today
Show for being too hot for morning TV
they had another actor play the
character of Danny tanner
I always feel bad about that the really
fit a pilot we shot was a hollow the
shot was townhouse makes me sad but the
same producers and other people in this
business have done that before with many
many shows Robin Williams was not the
first Mork the perfect strangers was was
not Mark linn-baker it was there was a
gay housekeeper in the pilot episode of
the Golden Girls
that guy got the boot I but that's what
I played on full house anyway but but I
ended up with the part because I was
fired and they made it available for me
and Jeff Franklin the exec producer
wanted me originally for it and Bob
Boyett and Tom Miller who still produce
fuller house it's complicated things
show business you're just so complicated
all you want to do is entertain a bunch
of people yeah and then all this stuff
happens and I played a character because
I wanted to be on three men and a baby
had just come out and we were talking
about that before we yeah we're rolling
on this fantastic showbiz
we saw the Gutenberg at dinner that
night out we did see the Gutenberg and
he brings his Bible and that went over
almost here the fish he had the fish and
he had enough for everyone and the water
guess what it turned it to anyway
sorry so this this part was something
that I wanted and three men and a baby
with Stephen and Ted Danson and Tom
Selleck yeah had this come out and so we
were that we were you know Dave and John
David Kahane John Stamos were already
diapering Ashley and Mary Kate and I was
not in those scenes so they reshot the
pilot and all of a sudden the show ABC
fought that keep it on doesn't happen
like that anymore they they put it on
twice a week it ran on Tuesdays didn't
run on Fridays uh-huh and then they
started to run it twice a week for a
while and then they ordered more
episodes and it wasn't doing very well
but they believed in it and we were on
against Seinfeld which also wasn't doing
very well right that so that's around
what like eighty nine ninety now at 87
88 oh wow yeah yeah so then 89 is yes
we're not doing well and then after four
years we started to do well we switched
studios from Sony because I know people
want to give their demographics right on
Google Maps to Warner Brothers to be on
the same stage exactly where fuller
house is done now and did the last four
years there and then it was a really big
hit and of course with network
television if you look at ratings now
you go my god how could they cancel it
with that share insane and then we were
offered to go to the CW or the WB I
can't remember what it was first cuz
it's all a blur we were offered one more
year but to go there and we just kind of
said John and I I kinda I thought we did
it you know we could kind of got
cancelled so why do we want to beg to go
somewhere else yes and they do that
sometimes do sitcoms and it never works
right know you're somewhere else and
then people find it would they do it for
is for syndication so oh what years is
that
everything looks different that looks
smaller right but it was the secret to
that show was that there was actual
affection between the cast and and in
good writing good moral things where
kids could watch your sister could watch
it yeah and feel good yeah afterward say
hi to my sister Thalia Thalia you were
great in Rocky and that's right that's
right tire there you go and I just your
brother loves you very very much and and
really appreciates that you would make
them all watch full house instead of
have a nice nice dinner that did make
the dinner nicer all right well let's do
just a little bit more on TV and I want
to talk politics with you and just sort
of deep your a philosophical guy I am a
philosophical guy it gets me in trouble
sometimes so you do fuller house yes big
star then you're also doing America's
Funniest Home Videos another thing where
it's a blooper show and I'm playing on
Sunday night 7 to 8 o'clock at night
people were in church that day so then
that night I'm hosting a show that has
to be done very palatable for America
and the world it was number one in China
it was that hard for you because you I
mean you really had to that that was
that was I had to you know it was a
little difficult and it was a gift horse
so the tree opens up you know it's the
number one show the producer Vindobona
called me one day on my curly cord car
phone and said we're number one and I
said you mean peepee anyway no I said
where I said were number one you know it
was a phenomenon and the the joke is if
you wanted to see a man get hit in the
nuts you had to come through me God was
the gatekeeper but in a funny way and
now it's all this I mean it's YouTube
will give you anything you want that's
exactly what I was gonna say that
somehow all of the stuff that people
click that's just quick and you watch
someone get smashed with something or
hit was on your fault it was all born
out of people walking around with
camcorders just because you guys were
like well let's do it he had the savvy
it was a famous show it came out of a
show in Japan which I think are still
partners with that I don't know that
business dealings but I'm gonna look it
up give me a minute
um I'm just getting on my phone you want
to pause you go again no I'll do it
right here
but it became a phenomenon because they
took they did it amazing they did the
grassroots approach which we don't see
anywhere mm-hmm they asked in People
magazine they took out an ad we have a
new show called America's Funniest Home
Videos full-page People magazine send
your VHS tapes and you could be on
television and you could win prize money
and that is how they got the first hour
of tapes and what happened to me was I
was doing a year of full house I get
this tape they said this is an amicably
a young man the man that now is is Walt
Disney is Bob Iger he is ABC he wanted
me for it
Ted Harbert was at the network wanted me
for it
from full house I seemed like a very
amicable guy they'd seen my stand-up
they didn't care they you know it was
like it wasn't as bluish as I became as
I got more free with myself yeah I was
gonna ask you about that it wasn't I
didn't Rob as many f-bombs I just but it
was all weird it all had things that you
can't say so what was that like for you
because he was so there I mean obviously
I'm not telling anything you know but
like it was so saccharine the jokes
you'd have to make a night and I'm proud
of them yeah I wrote it with two the
jokes were two Canadian guys so there
was an 18% exchange rate on the humor
but it was Todd thanks brother
may he rest in peace no his brother's a
lot
Todd Thicke Alan Thicke's brother and
Bob Arnot that's a writer from The
Smothers Brothers showing and we wrote
all the jokes we wrote 55 pages a week I
would do the voiceovers look how oh look
at me you know this bad Mel Blanc who
was that Warner Brothers Bugs Bunny if I
have to explain it yeah
millennial anyone who's Bugs Bunny thing
after this okay who is but but who is
Marvin the Martian yeah you make me so
mad
Marvin the Martian not a good impression
but it was a big production too I look I
wanted it to be a variety show so we
would have big guests on we'd have on
Rodney Dangerfield anybody that was a
friend of mine we'd had Leslie Nielsen
on Jonathan winters
cast a full house you know we did and it
was an hour and and it is still on to
this day a testament to vin and to the
people that make that show you know it
went to Tom Bergeron went through many
people who went through Richard kind
hosted at once daisy fuentes john
fugelsang yeah and there was no way to
stop it because it was a guaranteed
laugh and what I didn't like would would
bother me is if the guy falls in a
manhole and then you see somebody in the
audience throw their head back laughing
but you never see him climb out of the
manhole I'm like is he dead right you
know so I did that a charity for
people's nuts Bob Saget charity for
something yeah agates agates agates
something that would have yet because
there should have been people there were
a lot of nut hits it was oh the good
ones were when I was a six-year-old
taking a baseball bat just jab and his
dad yeah even just before this I was I
just quickly put America's Funniest Home
Videos in the youtube search well it's
just nut hit after not hit there's one
that's like six hundred nut hits in a
row I mean they just cut him real quick
just one thing that God to me was
someone had sent me a clip reel that I
think they aired on the show which was
old people falling and I had so and I
was like I'm glad I'm not there cuz that
was that was the only time I went like
oh come on and they're falling on cement
and stuff which sounds funny two bros in
a bar John beers but if you watch it
it's kind of snuff ish but as long as I
know everybody's okay I didn't want to
be a place where people filmed themself
hurting their friends so I felt like I
was hurting people right but that didn't
matter
I enjoyed for those first few years of
doing it I just I loved the hell out of
it I mean everybody was talking about it
and loving it I had friends calling me
going what is this yeah because no one
had seen it before but it's interesting
because it's like kind of one of those
things that we don't have anymore like
we don't have shows but we need that
right there are things like yes everyone
watches Game of Thrones or everyone
watches this or that on Netflix but we
don't have like sort of mainstream like
decent things that families can watch
anymore and
no and it's all the nonsense aside you
know and that's what I want to do that's
kind of stand I mean the woman talks
about a couple different things I want
to do something variety I don't know
what it is you know I love directing so
I just did this movie so we knock on
wood people go see this movie Benjamin
which we will we'll get to it for a
second all right let's get to it right
now if you want I feel that that was the
right way but I will give closure to
that last thing that's saying that I do
feel that there would be it would be
wonderful to have a family sit down on a
Sunday night I mean wonderful world of
Disney used to be on at 7 o'clock or
7:30 when I was a kid on NBC yeah and
you turn it on now and it's just another
one of those people punching each other
in in big sumo wrestler costumes yeah
and that's not what I want to see with
my family I wanted to see if that's
that's like--that's I say the cheap
replacement and that's variety yeah
that's that's reality variety but real
variety is we're gonna entertain you and
we're gonna bring out guests and it's
gonna be fun I mean I guess SNL is the
closest thing you have yeah but that's
not really it wouldn't play in front of
time but you want something you're
talking you want something that's funny
but also you can do some serious stuff
you want saying relevant I mean it's you
want again have everything yeah but but
I think it needs to make people laugh
the most and then it can have its its
waves in it then so I will be taking
pitches right after this all right let's
talk Benjamin and then Jame Benjamin
Benjamin comes out in the summer it is a
movie that I spent seven years on it is
an independent movie very low-budget I'm
just getting it in the nuts
no one no one gets it there is a fight
in it at least I can't even I can't tell
you who me and Dave Foley I won't talk I
don't want no no spoiler alerts it's
about it's really about a dysfunctional
family which is most families and we
believe that I directed it and I acted
in it with some amazing people that I'll
name really quickly which are Rob
Corddry who's hilarious Kevin Pollak
Cheri Oteri Dave Foley max Burkholder
plays my son he was on parenthood we
think that he is on crystal meth so it's
a dark comedy oh I thought you met the
actor no not where movies
movies about sorry I wonder plays
Benjamin no sorry we believe all the
actors don't know what you're doing all
the actors in the movie were on crystal
meth during the making of them in order
to be able to survive working with me
yeah because I was out of my mind
because we had a 15 day shoot it was a
low low-budget ouchies yeah I know this
show has longer to shoot my movie and so
my in the movie my son Benjamin we
believe his own crystal meth and so
Marilyn rice cub plays my girlfriend
she's from 24 very good comedian actress
and she posts on Facebook that we need
an intervention for the boy and that's
not where you post an intervention
people don't post interventions on
Facebook it's supposed to be kind of
quiet and properly maybe a note posted
and so Rob Corddry is our family
gynecologist he leads the intervention
and Kevin Pollak plays my brother and
peri gilpin Zin and Clara Mamet got to
have a Mamet she's so good at it and
David haw and Jonny Weston and it's just
it's an in samel and it takes place on
one night and it's just basically the
one line would be on it that the people
the person you think has the problem
it's the people and I can't really give
very much more the family the family the
your family is the woman the prow you
know people somebody right or one line
for this movie quick yeah we need it for
the one sheet but the people that you
think have the problem mmm the people
that are accusing someone of having the
problem are the ones with the problem oh
that's a spoiler alert that's a little
bit of a spoiler but I feel like that
transcends this movie that's just a
general thing it's a serious movie with
a with a with a comedy bit to it and I'm
very proud of it yeah and so you know
thank you for letting me plug all of
that yeah let's move to politics
[Music]
you
[Music]